one of the most vile and disgusting
things that one can do when it comes to
money is to raise money supposedly to
help sick people and then take that
money and use it for something else
particularly something for profit or
personal enrichment according to a
report released yesterday by Forbes not
exactly a liberal rag Donald Trump's son
Eric Trump shifted money supposedly
raised to help kids with cancer into one
of the Trump businesses Eric Trump has
this golf tournament that he does to
raise money for st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital which is at sort of
the forefront of research into pediatric
cancer and as he did this tournament
Eric Trump started charging the
fundraiser money for the use of his own
golf course which is a way to direct
money raised in donations for cancer
research to the Trump family and their
for-profit business this is made even
worse by the fact that Eric Trump has
always claimed that he is able to hold
the event on Trump golf courses free of
charge and that much of the food drinks
entertainment and equipment is either
comped or paid for by sponsors according
to tax filings obtained by Forbes the
event expenses averaged about $50,000
the first four years that Eric Trump did
this in 2011 all of a sudden the
expenses rose to one hundred and forty
two thousand dollars and this appears to
be because Trump learned that the course
was being used without a charge became
upset and decided to start charging his
own fundraiser for use of his own golf
course this is a form of money
laundering right you're taking nonprofit
charity donations that you are inducing
by the creation of this event yourself
and then creating profits from them and
we have a quote from from the Forbes
article which says quote in effect
though this maneuver would appear to
have more in common with a drug cartels
money laundering operation than a
charity's best practices textbook that
$100,000 and outside donations to the
Donald J Trump foundation remember Trump
himself didn't give to his own
foundation at this time passed through
the Eric Trump Foundation and wound up
in the coffer
of Donald Trump's private businesses
this is rotten to the core I mean really
really low yeah we always hear from
conservatives that we need less of a
welfare state in lower taxes right so
that the rich are able to provide money
to the charities that they support of
course
apparently not I mean this is the
greediest thing you can do in at the
expense of children with cancer this is
one of the lowest things you could do
and it's really bad David Farenthold
from the Washington Post has been all
over the Trump family's lies about
donations and charity and giving and
whatever he's been posting back and
forth his communications with Eric Trump
and he first posted that here's the
question he sent to Eric Trump after the
Forbes story saying Eric hello Dave here
again from the Washington Post sure Eric
Trump loves getting these emails from
David Farenthold I just saw that Forbes
story saying your charity actually
didn't pay your dad's company for rental
of the course in those past years it
surprised me since you had told me
categorically and repeatedly last year
that he allowed you to use the golf
course for free and that the payment
listed on the Eric Trump Foundation's
990s were just pass-throughs to allow
you to pay other vendors more easily so
then Eric Trump responded and again
David Farenthold posted to the Twitter
to his Twitter saying contrary to recent
reports at no time did the Trump
administration profit in any way from
the foundation or any of its activities
while people can disagree on political
issues to infer malicious intent on a
charity that has changed changed so many
lives is not only shameful but is truly
disgusting at the end of the day the
only people who lose are the children of
st. Jude and other incredibly worthy
causes
David Ferran holds follow-up question as
yet unanswered Eric thank you when you
say profit here I want to be clear about
what that means were there instances
where the Eric Trump foundation did pay
the Trump Organization for services
rendered the use of a Trump golf course
etcetera but only paid the cost of those
services with no extra profit added on
top smart question from David Farenthold
no answer so far yeah and I thought that
the Trump golf courses and his business
overall was so profitable that they can
just put aside $142,000 what's that to
them absolutely and it really speaks to
uh the the continuing and and
corroborated story of unaccounted money
supposedly for one charity or another
remember the unaccounted for millions
for veterans this is the lowest of below
and you can discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it today's episode
of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS